la vida cotidiana de no deseo de hoy es
muy diferente de nuestra vida normal
porque la gente Aunque nosotros estamos
acostumbrados a la guerra porque uno
puede acostumbrarse a todo tenemos
muchas dudas de futuro muchos han
incertidumbres y muchas angustias y la
primera es la situación con la
electricidad en Ucrania la situación
holandesa fue peor que en todo el país y
mucha gente Simplemente no puede
trabajar especialmente gente como yo que
trabaja en el remoto y el café es en
gasolineras hay muchos jóvenes con
ordenadores con teléfonos que intentan a
trabajar o simplemente conectarse con el
mundo porque cuando no tuvimos la
electricidad
conexión móvil tampoco funcionaba Claro
que es muy difícil y por eso la gente
sigue saliendo de esa a otras partes del
país
[Música]
febrero en marzo fueron los meses más
difíciles de mi vida nosotros teníamos
muchísimo miedo de perder nuestro hogar
nuestros seres queridos y
nuestra preocupación será por
posibilidad de ocupación rusa la ciudad
de ahora casi vacía el centro estaba
bloqueado para los civiles Y nadie pudo
entrar por ejemplo en teatro de ópera
yo veo el futuro duro espero victorioso
Claro que ahora nadie de nosotros puede
saber cuándo se termina la guerra pero
todos estamos seguros de cómo